please come to order
quorum being present without objection
the chair is authorized to declare a
recess at any time
pursuant to committee rule two and house
rule 11 Clause 2 the chair may postpone
further proceedings today and the
question of approving any measure or
matter or adopting an amendment for
which a recorded vote for the yeas and
nays are ordered
you
pursuant to notice I now call up the
committee report for a resolution
recommending that the House of
Representatives find William Barr
attorney general US Department of
Justice in contempt
for refusal to comply with a subpoena
duly issued by the Committee on the
Judiciary
for purposes of markup and move that the
committee reported favorably to the
house as chairman I demand the question
of consideration
before we read the bill I believe this
is when the motion lies
you
you
you
the question of consideration is not
debatable the question is shall the
committee consider the committee report
all those in favor say aye
aye opposed the eyes have it roll call
please close requested the clerk will
call the roll
mr. Nadler hi
mr. Nadler votes I missed Lofgren miss
Lofgren votes
I miss Jackson Lee miss Jackson Lee
votes aye mr. Cohen mr. Cohen votes aye
mr. Johnson of Georgia mr. Deutsch mr.
Deutsch votes
I miss bass miss bass votes aye mr.
Richmond mr. Richmond votes yes mr.
Jeffries mr. Cicilline mr. Cicilline
votes aye mr. swallow
mr. Liu mr. Liu votes aye mr. Raskin mr.
Raskin votes
I miss jayapal miss jayapal votes
I miss Demings miss Demings votes aye
mr. Correa mr. Correa votes
I miss Scanlon miss Scanlon votes
I miss Garcia I miss Garcia votes aye
mr. Noguchi
mr. [ __ ] boats I miss Macbeth miss
Macbeth votes aye mr. Stanton mr.
Stanton votes
I miss Dean I miss Dean votes I miss
Rooke arsal Powell misma carcel Powell
votes I miss Escobar I miss Escobar
votes aye mr. Collins mr. Collins votes
no mr. Sensenbrenner mr. Sensenbrenner
votes no mr. Chabot mr. gohmert mr.
gohmert votes no mr. Jordan mr. Jordan
votes no mr. buck mr. Ratcliffe mr.
Radcliffe votes no mr. OB missed
mr. Johnson of Louisiana mr. Johnson of
Louisiana votes no mr. BIG's mr. baek's
votes no mr. McLintock miss let's go
miss let's go votes no mr. Russian
thaller
mr. Russian thaller votes no mr. Klein
mr. Klein votes no mr. Armstrong mr.
Armstrong votes no mr. Stubbe
mr. gates you are not recorded mr. gates
with snow
gentleman from Georgia yes mr. Johnson
of Georgia votes yes lady from Florida
Oh is there any member of the committee
who wishes to vote who hasn't voted
clerk clerk will report
you
mr. chairman there are 22 eyes and 12
nose the emotion for consideration is
adopted the clerk will report the
committee report
resolution recommending that the House
of Representatives find William P bar
Attorney General US Department of
Justice in contempt of Congress for
refusal to comply with the subpoena duly
issued by the Committee on the judiciary
without objection the committee report
is considered as read and open for
amendment at any point
I will begin by recognizing myself for
an opening statement today we consider a
report recommending that the House of
Representatives hold Attorney General
William bar in contempt of Congress for
defying a valid subpoena issued by this
committee this is not a step we take
lightly it is the culmination of nearly
three months of requests discussions and
negotiations with the Department of
Justice for the complete unredacted
report by special counsel Muller into
Russian interference in the 2016
election along with the underlying
evidence I appreciate the fact that the
Department responded to the offer we
made to them last week and met with us
yesterday in a last-minute effort to
reach an accommodation we heard the
Department out we responded to them in
good faith and after all was said and
done we unfortunately were still unable
to reach agreement and we proceeded with
our markup today as I've said before we
remain ready and willing to consider any
reasonable offer made by the department
even after today's vote but if a letter
I received late last night from the
department is any indication I am
concerned that the department is heading
in the wrong direction
in response to our latest good-faith
offer the department abruptly announced
that if we move forward today it would
ask President Trump to invoke what it
refers to as a protective assertion of
executive privilege on all of the
materials subject to our subpoena just
minutes ago it took that dramatical
staff
besides miss applying the doctrine of
executive privilege since the White
House waived these privileges long ago
and the department seemed open to
sharing these materials with us just
yesterday this decision represents a
clear escalation and the Trump
administration's blanket defiance of
Congress constitutionally mandated
duties I hope that the department will
think better of this last-minute
outbursts
and return to negotiations as a co-equal
branch of government we must have access
to the materials that we need to fulfill
our constitutional responsibilities in a
manner consistent with past precedent
this is information we are legally
entitled to receive and we are
constitutionally obligated to review and
I would remind the members that the
mollow report is no ordinary
run-of-the-mill document it details
significant misconduct involving the
president including his campaigns
willingness and eagerness to accept help
from a hostile foreign government
numerous missed statements if not
outright lies concerning these act those
acts and eleven separate incidents of
obstructive behavior by the president
that more than 700 former prosecutors
have told us warrant criminal indictment
if Congress is not entitled to the full
unredacted Mullah report one must wonder
what document we would be entitled to
our exhaustive negotiations with the
Department of Justice have unfortunately
left us back where we began with
unprecedented obstruction by the
administration that has now announced
its intention to block all attempts at
congressional oversight of the executive
branch it is our constitutional duty to
respond let me be clear the information
we request we are requesting is entirely
within our legal rights to receive and
there's no different that from what has
been provided to Congress on numerous
occasions going back nearly a century
but we do not need to go back that far
to find the precedent as recently as the
last Congress under Republican control
the department produced more than eight
hundred eighty thousand pages of
sensitive investigative materials
pertaining to its investigation of
Hillary Clinton as well as voluminous
other material relating to the Russian
investigation and other ongoing
investigations that production included
highly classified material notes from
FBI interviews internal text messages
and law enforcement memoranda with
respect to grand jury information in
past cases involving allegations of
presidential misconduct or misconduct by
other high-ranking public officials the
Department of Justice as a matter of
course
sought the permission of a court to
release relevant information to Congress
if not to the public notably this
includes several cases that were not
impeachment inquiries including the
investigation into former agriculture
secretary Mike SV and the iran-contra
investigations as well as other
investigations that were not governed by
the Independent Counsel law but no
matter the fact that the law and history
clearly support the release to Congress
of this kind of information the Trump
administration has taken obstruction of
Congress to new heights
unfortunately the Attorney General has
been all too willing to support the
president in this endeavor I would also
like to respond to two of the concerns
often raised by my good friend the
ranking member he asks how can the
committee hold the Attorney General in
contempt for merely complying with the
laws on the books and how can we hold
him in contempt when I have refused an
offer to allow me to see certain
redacted portions of the report the
answers are simple first we issued a
valid subpoena for the full report and
all of the underlying evidence the
department has come nowhere close to
satisfying its obligations under that
subpoena the department has never cited
a legal basis for withholding the
underlying evidence including last
night's threat to invoke executive
privilege which was utterly without
credibility merit or legal or factual
basis as is of course the assertion of
or the statement that they will assert
the executive privilege by the White
House this morning to the extent that we
have asked for access to grand jury
information which is protected by
federal law all we have ever asked is
that the department join us in
petitioning the court to determine if it
is proper for us to have access to this
material the department as I said has
done this on many occasions in the past
we asked for a commitment to join us in
that effort again last night as it has
done in many previous cases and the
department refused second with respect
to the offer to limit and to lift some
of the redactions for me and a handful
of my colleagues
the department has placed unacceptable
limitations on access to that
information
their offer would block the members of
this committee from reading those
sections of the report for themselves it
would require me to leave my notes
the Department of Justice it would
prevent me from speaking with my
colleagues with other members of the
committee about what I might see what
good is it
of what use can this committee make of
information that I have but can't
discuss with any other member of the
committee I have consistently stated
that if we are to do our jobs as members
of the House Judiciary Committee all of
the members require meaningful access to
the report and the underlying documents
we need to be able to confer with each
other about what we have seen we need to
be able to take official action on what
we have seen if warranted and if
necessary we need to be able to inform a
court of law of what we have learned
even if perhaps under seal if we can
find an accommodation that satisfies
those basic principles I would be happy
to continue negotiating with the
Department of Justice but now by
invoking executive privilege and all of
the materials subject to our subpoena
that process has come to a screeching
halt
the administration has announced loud
and clear that it does not recognize
Congress as a co-equal branch of
government with independent
constitutional oversight Authority and
it will continue to wage its campaign of
obstruction when the administration says
it will oppose all subpoenas presumably
regardless of its merits it is saying
that it does not recognize Congress
having a constitutional oversight
authority over the executive branch and
to those who consider the matter case
closed in the words of some of our
leaders and aware just to simply move on
I would say that to do so is to announce
loud and clear that such a course of
action as the effect of aiding and
abetting in the administration's
campaign of total blanket and
unprecedented obstruction the Trump
administration and its enablers they
brazenly try to govern to cover up the
misdeeds uncovered by the Special
Counsel but in this committee we will
represent the American people and ensure
the truth is known
I urge my colleagues to think about how
the department's latest position and
their insistence on ignoring our
subpoena affects our committee over time
our fight is not just about the Muller
report although we must have access to
the Mullen report our fight is about
defending the rights of Congress as an
independent branch to hold the president
any president accountable every day we
learn of new efforts by this
administration to Stonewall Congress and
through Congress to Stonewall the
American people the Ways and Means
Committee has been denied the
president's tax returns when the law
states clearly that they are entitled to
them upon request the chairman of the
Oversight and Reform Committee has been
sued in his personal capacity to prevent
them from acquiring certain financial
records from the Trump Organization the
president has stated that his
administration will oppose all subpoenas
and in fact virtually all document
requests are going unsatisfied witnesses
are refusing to show up at hearings this
is unprecedented if allowed to go
unchecked this obstruction means the end
of congressional oversight as a co-equal
branch of government we should not and
cannot allow this to continue or we will
not be a co-equal branch of government
I urge my colleagues whether or not you
care to see the full Mullah report and
we should all want to see the complete
report to stand up for the institution
we are proud to serve I expect that we
will have a full debate today on the
measure before us I hope that at the end
of it we will do what is right no person
and certainly not the top law
enforcement officer in the country can
be permitted to flout the will of
Congress and to defy a valid subpoena no
person not the Attorney General not the
president can be permitted to be above
the law that is what is at stake today I
urge all of my colleagues to support
this report I now recognize the ranking
member of the Judiciary Committee the
gentleman from Georgia mr. Collins for
his opening statement
Thank You mr. chairman miss chairman
this and the folks watching here this
slog continues last week I urge you and
the my fellow members of the Judiciary
Committee Democrats to respect the
histories and traditions of this
committee and conduct his business
accordingly we still have a crisis on
our southern border China is stealing
our intellectual property yet here we
are wasting another valuable week of
legislating Calendar against the
majority's war against the
administration today we are meeting to
consider a resolution to hold Attorney
General Bill Barr in contempt of
Congress so let's take just a few
moments and go through this what is the
justification for holding attorney
general Barr in contempt of Congress
perhaps if he failed to abide by the
special counsel regulations no he went
above and beyond what the regulation is
required by transmitting the full report
to Congress with limited reductions
could it be that the Attorney General
failed to accommodate the Chairman's
demands for information
no he offered to let the Chairman and
five other Democrat leaders review the
less redacted port at the Department of
Justice including a 99.9% unredacted
volume on instruction in an odd move for
anyone demanding access to information
the Chairman and the other elected
Democrats given access have declined to
view that report the Attorney General
also volunteered to testify before this
committee about the report's conclusions
in his role in sharing the report and as
we all witnessed the Democratic
gamesmanship forced the Attorney General
to forego the scheduled hearing last
week on Monday the Justice Farman
offered to meet to discuss
accommodations yesterday they made a
reasonable offer to avert this spectacle
and once again they were rebuffed in the
Chairman declined perhaps then the
Democrats believe that there has been an
unreasonable delay in the Justice
Department's response to their subpoena
no that's not true either
in fact the chairman is moving to this
contempt resolution at lightning speed
it has been less than 20 days since the
Chairman Nadler subpoenaed documents
from the Justice Department when the
Oversight Committee held Eric Attorney
General Eric Holder in contempt more
than 250 days had passed between the
subpoena and the committee's vote to
hold him in contempt
more than 450 days passed between the
committee's initial request to the
Justice Department and the committee's
contempt vote judiciary Democrats are
moving more than ten times faster than
oversight did with holder they have
moved from request to contempt vote in
only forty three days and yet the
Justice Department is still at the
negotiating table waiting for the
Democrats to arrive in good faith why
this rush without any valid legislative
or administrative region we can only
assume the Democrats that are led by the
chairman have resolved to sully the bill
bars good name and reputation to
accomplish two goals first Democrats are
angry the special counsels report did
not produce the material or collusions
they expected to pave their path to
impeaching the president I feel
compelled remind everyone the report
found despite offers to do so no one
from the Trump campaign knowingly
conspired with the Russian government
and you can't help but notice the phrase
Russian collusion has vanished from the
Democratic talking points and left a
void in the narrative since the special
council did not make a prosecutor or
determination instruction which was his
job the Attorney General and the Deputy
Attorney General did so according to
their mandates as law enforcement
officials while giving no credence to
the office of legal counsels opinion
regarding data sitting presidents as a
result they're angry they're angry
nation's chief law enforcement officer
and his deputy had the audacity to
decide the evidence didn't support
charges for obstruction and
investigation into something the
president didn't do second Democrats are
afraid of what the Attorney General will
find when he completes his ongoing
review of FISA abuses the Justice
Department including how the Russian
investigation began multiple news
reports have suggested those conclusions
could be explosive could in careers and
could even lead to criminal prosecution
rather than face that the Democrats have
resolved to neutralize bill Barr by
attacking him in the office in his
Tegrity and his a career this is the
first step what a cynical mean-spirited
counterproductive irresponsible step it
is meanwhile our economy is surging
unemployment among several Minari groups
is a historic low a recent Washington
Post poll shows cratering support for
impeachment but Democrats have no plans
no purpose and no viable legislative
agenda beyond attacking this
administration the house is more than
four months into a Democratic majority
how many bills passed by this committee
have been signed into law mr. Chairman I
implore you to see reason
I ask
you recognise the craving and insincere
politics that seemed to be yielding no
dividends for the American people we've
talked on multiple occasions improved at
last week's pharmaceutical markup that I
stand ready to work with you to promote
solutions
I will not though become a bystander as
we assail the Attorney General and this
committee our democracy deserves better
finally mr. chairman I'd like to quote a
fellow member of Congress as a member of
Congress I treat assertions of executive
privilege very seriously I believe they
should be used only sparingly in this
case it seems the clearer the
administration was forced into a
position by the committee's insistence
on pushing forward with contempt despite
the Attorney General's good-faith offer
mr. chairman it did not have to be this
way we could have postponed today's vote
and accepted the Attorney General's
offer instead by not honoring the
Constitution's charge to seek
accommodations when possible the
prestige of this committee has been
diminished as a result that should
concern us all I quote Elijah Cummings
in that case of course the committee did
seek accommodations in this case this
committee did not and in just a
difference of opinion between me and the
Chairman there has been no escalation of
this except on the side of the majority
you have to have both sides at the table
for accommodations that's the way this
process works that is what I've just
laid out ten times faster than even Eric
Holder and when we get into the other
issues that have been discarded here and
asked in how we deal with this is going
forward with what will be the precedent
for the future and will be the president
for what we have with that I yield back
Thank You mr. Collins without objection
all other opening statements will be
included in the record I now recognize
myself for purposes of offering an
amendment in the nature of a substitute
the clerk will report the amendment
amendment in the nature of a substitute
to the committee report for the
resolution recommending that the House
of Representatives find William P bar
objection the amendment in the nature of
a substitute will be considered as read
and shall be considered as base text for
purposes of amendment I will recognize
myself to explain the amendment the
amendment in the nature of a substitute
contains a technical change to page two
of the committee report
simply changes the reference of that
patient to Judiciary Committee to the
Committee on the judiciary with this
modest change I urge the committee to
support the amendment I now recognize
the ranking member of the full committee
mr. Collins for any comments he may have
on the amendment only amendment itself I
thank you mr. Chairman I don't have any
as far as the amendment nation I will
make up one comment there was it was
made in your previous opening statement
the chair the chairman of now the
Oversight Committee was not sued in his
personal quest he was served in his
official capacity in that committee and
just a clarification for the record
there as we go forward with that I have
no objection to the ANS are there any
amendments to the amendment in the
nature of a substitute who seeks
recognition mr. chairman for what
purpose does the gentleman from Ohio
seek mr. Chairman I moved for our
classwork gentleman is recognized
Thank You mr. chairman our Democratic
colleagues seem to be on a mission
they're determined to destroy Attorney
General bar or at least discredit him in
the icy American people the Attorney
General agreed to appear before this
committee last week and was ready to
answer assessment and all questions
about the mall report however miss
chairman you and your Democratic
colleagues on this committee decided
that instead of just answering questions
from members of the committee well we
unprecedented ly we're also going to
require him to be grilled by a bunch of
partisan staff lawyers of course the
Attorney General wisely said no way and
now you're determined to find him in
contempt in my view as somebody who
served on this committee for 23 years I
think it's disgraceful last week when
the Attorney General refused to show up
for this committees kangaroo court the
majority set up an empty chair a chicken
and pretty much made a mockery of this
committee a committee that was once led
by the likes of Daniel Webster it's
worth noting that Attorney General did
appear before the Senate Judiciary
Committee the day before he was
scheduled to come here where the
unreasonable demand that he be queried
by staff attorneys was not made senators
did the questioning themselves as is
normal and the same should have been the
case here instead of chicken gate and
let's be clear it
wasn't a day at the beach in the Senate
for the Attorney General the Senators
themselves were perfectly capable of
being rude abusive and arrogant all by
themselves they didn't need their staff
to do it for them so why this passion to
tear into William bar an attorney
general is up to this point in his
career considered a person of upstanding
in fact outstanding character well first
our Democratic colleagues are apparently
really ticked off about the molar report
that it found that the whole rush
inclusion thing was a big fat zero and
even though the obstruction of justice
allegation wasn't as clear-cut Special
Counsel moer
found that there was insufficient
evidence to pursue a charge against
President Trump or against anyone else
for that matter excuse me but we
embargoed that so Democrats are mad
about that but what I think is even more
important is that our Democratic
colleagues are afraid they're afraid
that unlike former attorney general
sessions who had recused himself from
anything related to the Moller
investigation bill Barr is going to dig
into the origins of the bogus Russian
collusion allegation itself the Clinton
campaign funding of a steel dossier was
the actual collusion between the
Russians and the political campaign is
that's something that's finally going to
be looked into that was the real
political collusion with the Russians
the FBI's involvement in trying to tip a
presidential election in favor one
candidate over another the whole Peter
struck Lisa page all of that the idea
that Trump may have been right that his
campaign really was spied on by elements
of the Obama administration despite the
fact that this accusation was met with
such derision by most of the mainstream
press at the time the bottom line is
many Democrats on this committee and in
fact many Democrats in both the House
and the Senate apparently believe that
finding out the truth in these matters
may not be helpful to them in the
upcoming election cycle and the best way
to undermine the results of the
investigation the true investigation
which is really about to happen might
speed to destroy the credibility of a
guy who's doing the investigation the
Attorney General William bar and let's
begin that process apparently according
to the folks on the other side of the
island the chairman included by finding
him in contempt that's the way we can
really discredit him least that's the
way I see it and I yield back before I
proceed to the next statement let me
just point clarify a point of apparent
confusion we are not proposing to hold
the Attorney General in contempt for not
just showing up last week he didn't show
up last week but that has nothing to do
with this motion for contempt we are
proposing to hold him in contempt for
for ignoring for not satisfying the
subpoena for the production of documents
namely the unredacted Mulla report and
underlying evidence who seeks
recognition
gentlemen from the gentlelady from Texas
for what purpose does gentlelady from
Texas
thank the last word gentlelady is
recognized
I'm pausing for a moment because I do
think this is a moment in history and I
appreciate my good friends on the other
side of the aisle but having received a
letter both from a copy of the letter to
the President United States by general
bar and a letter from the Department of
Justice indicating after their
purposeful collapse of the negotiations
well intentioned by the staff and House
Judiciary Committee I can only conclude
that the president now seeks to take a
wrecking ball through the Constitution
of the United States of America for the
first time in the history of the United
States a president is now exerting
executive privilege over every aspect of
life that the American people desire to
have information whether or not their
Affordable Care Act is dissolving the
pre-existing condition whether or not
children are being separated from their
parents whether or not the environment
is being destroyed anything that the
Congress wants to do on behalf of the
American people is now being alleged to
be under the jurisdiction of privilege
then of course we have to surmise that
this is an absolute lawless behavior by
this administration the general attorney
general actions are contemptuous and
insulting to Congress but we're simply
the tools it is to the American people
to broaden the executive privilege and
ignore the constant accommodations that
chairman Nadler has made and our staff
in working to work out three simple
points give us all of the documents
unredacted Muller report for the
American people to see work with us on
grand jury materials not to undermine if
you will any ongoing investigations and
work with us to list the documents by
priority that is very simple to recount
facts of yesteryear does not even speak
to the fact of the hundreds of
investigations that my good friends when
President Trump and the Republican
houses
existed they never ceased they never
cease going after Secretary Clinton
getting 880,000 documents in a magazi
hearing that went forever and ever and
never found anything I happen to believe
700 former prosecutors who indicated
that the Muller report describes several
axes satisfy all elements for an
obstruction charge conduct congressman
Jackson Lee didn't say this chairman
Nadler did not say this precise
statement as a former federal prosecutor
it's 700 who indicated that the actions
of this president warrant an obstruction
charge in addition we have a right to
understand the underlying reasons
regarding the collusion report but the
very fact that the collusion part of the
Muller report recounts the constant
interaction of Trump operatives with
Russian adversaries the American people
should be wary and they should ask us
why and we should write legislation as
I've introduced HR 23:53 that says if
you interact with a Russian operative or
foreign adversary as a campaign
committee or candidate you must report
it to the FBI and so this is part of our
legislative work and I would argue the
case that our friends on the other side
of the aisle should not be noted in
history of standing at the door of
justice in this room and putting up a
stop sign that we cannot pursue the
truth on behalf of the American people
we have gone over and over and over
again that there are allegations of
obstruction of justice that need to be
heard in front of this committee I say
this mr. Malla
a former marine a man of integrity I
will say to him in the open proceeding
we welcome you to come and explain your
position on how disturbed you were that
the Attorney General characterized your
report as an exoneration
of this administration secondarily I
want to say to mr. McGann you are a
private citizen you have every right to
present yourself to this body and also
that the conduct of President Trump
described in special councilor mullahs
report would in the case of any other
person if not having the office of legal
counsel policy against and dining and
sitting president would result in felony
charges there are people incarcerated
right now because of lesser charges I
don't want to target the president mr.
chairman I simply want to find the truth
for the American people and that's why
we're here today to vote on this
citation for lacking a producing of
documents I yield back
for what purpose does the gentleman seek
rank the last word and home is
recognized mr. Chairman I think we ought
to step back from the political rhetoric
and asked exactly what this contempt
citation deals with and I'm going to try
to use my time to do that first and
foremost and most concerning to every
American or at least it should be is the
fact that they want an unredacted report
that includes information on grand jury
testimony the committee by making this
insistence and issuing the subpoena is
telling the Attorney General of the
United States to commit a crime because
it's a crime for anybody to disclose
grand jury material to anybody else
that includes the Attorney General and
includes the prosecutors in the Justice
Department and includes the witnesses
who have been subpoenaed and have
testified before the grand jury it means
everybody and if the grand jury system
is to work and remember witnesses can't
even bring their attorneys in to a grand
jury then the secrecy is going to have
to be maintained now all of us know that
it's really impossible for the people
who work on this case
a little hill to keep a secret if there
is an unredacted version completely
unredacted version including the grand
jury testimony which is unredacted it'll
be on the front page of every newspaper
in the country within 48 hours and
talked about incessantly on the cable
news shows whether you'll watch fox news
or whether you watch MSNBC now I think
it is absolutely shocking that the
majority of this committee is going to
ask the chief law enforcement officer of
the United States to commit a crime
shocking and there are no exceptions to
what is to be Duke's disclosed in this
unredacted version that includes the
grand jury testimony and by citing the
Attorney General of the United States
for contempt of Congress for saying I'm
standing up for the law I am NOT going
to break the law by complying with that
part of your subpoena shows an overreach
on the part of the majority if we are to
be a government of laws and not of men
or people then we have to obey the law
on this end of Pennsylvania Avenue as
well as on the other end of Pennsylvania
Avenue and we are not doing that now
what else has been redacted
there has been redactions relative to
ongoing investigations now do we want to
let the people the Justice Department is
investigating know all about the ongoing
investigations I don't think the public
interest is served by that whether
somebody is guilty or not should be
determined by the jury in a trial that's
what the American system is and that's
what a lot of the Bill of Rights
protects you also have a protection
against people who are peripherally
involved in that
that they were just on the edges of this
they were interviewed and nothing came
of the interview because they didn't
have any evidence on what was being
investigated but there's a character
assassination squad running around this
town that even if you are on the
periphery it went and voluntarily talked
to the FBI or mr. Muller's team now
you're gonna end up having your good
name and your reputation smeared even
though it didn't do anything so this is
definitely an overreach those reactions
the redactions excuse me
ended up being justified redactions and
i can understand the reluctance on the
part of the Attorney General or anybody
else that watches the way this
institution and the people who work here
operate that anything that is supposed
to not get out in the public realm well
get out in the public realm with a leak
and if this place weren't as leaky as a
sieve I would not be opposed to what the
Chairman is doing because I've stood up
for oversight during my entire career in
this body but it is leaky as a sieve and
I think what we're doing here is forcing
the Attorney General to break the law
the place in jeopardy innocent people
you know who are not involved in any of
the things that mr. Muller ended up
investigating and shaming ourselves in
the process my time is up what purpose
does the gentleman from Tennessee seek
recognition
right the last word and was recognized
Thank You mr. chair the Attorney General
has been contemptuous of this committee
and of the Congress he was contemptuous
last week when he didn't come when he
couldn't dictate the terms of the
hearing he's contemptuous this week when
he will not bring forth papers the
Chairman has tried to reach an
accommodation with the Justice
Department all cases in the past
such issues of raise been raised about
grand jury testimony the Attorney
General has gone with the majority party
the Chairman to the district court and
asked that that information be released
to the committee for its purposes this
attorney general has not done that if he
would have done that and tried to make a
reasonable accommodation to join with us
and going to judge Powell we might not
be in this situation but there's been
nothing reasonable from this attorney
general mr. Sensenbrenner talks about
people on the periphery we don't know
who those people were but we know that
bill Barr decided who was testimony
which testimony be redacted because
people were on the periphery and to
protect their reputations this is the
same person who gave a three-and-a-half
page summary of the Muller report that
did not according to special counsel
Muller who knew it better than anyone
else
reflect the character and the spirit of
the report and he knew mr. Muller
objected to it for not being an accurate
representation of his work and yet he
did it and when asked about it by mr.
Christie in committee he had no idea
that mr. Muller or anybody in the Muller
Special Counsel investigation would have
objected that's not true he lied when
mr. Crist
asked him that question that's beyond
contempt that's alive so we're depending
on mr. Bars determining who was on the
periphery and what their reputations
would suffer we're talking about the
opportunity for Congress to do its
proper oversight as described in an
article 1 of the Constitution which is
being trampled upon the Trump
administration refuses to respond to any
subpoenas destroying article 1 and
Congress's perogative now we had a
question I think it was a maybe the
ranking member said we should be doing
legislation and how many signatures how
many bills have been signed into law by
this committee well ask Mitch McConnell
who has declared that the Senate is a
graveyard for all legislation that comes
from the house we have passed
outstanding legislation out of this
committee it's gone to the graveyard
where Mitch McConnell who first
Hills Supreme Court nominees of the last
president knighted States in his one
year before and boyd's and frustrates
the constitutional prerogative of the
President to nominate members to the
Supreme Court but now frustrates the
other house by not having hearings
whatsoever
somebody said we're afraid yes we're
afraid we're afraid of the loss of the
rule of law we're afraid of the loss of
the power of Congress to be an
independent and co-equal branch of
government and we face that today if we
don't stand up and somebody else said
that Russia there are no connections and
nothing was Russian collusion
well those mental reports said there was
sweeping and systematic efforts by the
Russians to influence our election and
they were done so to help Trump and the
molar reports showed lots of connections
between the Trump campaign and Russia
lots of contacts and didn't but didn't
show that he had all of the elements to
prove beyond a reasonable doubt that
they conspired together there's a big
difference between not having
connections and having guilt beyond a
reasonable ballot then mr. Trump gets on
the telephone with mr. Putin and has a
90 minute conversation or something like
that where he can see on a phone call
that he smiled at him and he gets
flattered and never broaches the subject
of Russian interference and our next
election or Russian interference
whatsoever that was one of the prime
parts of the Muller report that the
Russians that are feared and that our
intelligence officials had confirmed and
told us and our FBI has told us and that
we know they did it in 2018 and they're
gonna do it more in 2020 but our
President did not even mention it to mr.
Putin that is scary we are afraid of
interference in the 2020 elections and
we need to be and we need to be because
we've got a man who has been suggested
might be financially dependent on the
Russians why would he be financially
dependent on the Russians will we now
and know he lost over a billion dollars
in a decade in the 80s and 90s he was
broke no bank would loan him a penny he
was broke and if it weren't for him
being president he'd be in prison with
Michael Cohen today as individual one
and he obstructed justice as the Mullah
report says it's though we are in danger
we need to respond and we need to act
for the people of the United States of
America I yield back the balance of my
time
what purpose does the gentleman from
Texas seek recognition as to strike the
last word gentleman is recognized
thank you I'm really here in mourning
for a once-great Judiciary Committee I
know my first term Oh five and six
I saw our current chairman as a champion
for privacy rights for civil rights for
Fourth Amendment rights fifth Amendment
rights and something dramatically has
changed over the years
there was concern back then about too
much power through the FISA courts
through the Patriot Act and we shared a
number of those concerns
and now this committee majority is on
the wrong side of a very important
historic time we've never had the
intelligence community the FBI people at
the top of the DOJ abusing their powers
to create a case against a president
where there was none
where assets were actually used to try
to set up members of the Trump campaign
when there was no case to try to create
a case we ought to be all over that we
ought to be demanding answers from the
FISA judge or judges who were either a
contempt to have fraud committed against
their courts or were complicit maybe it
was Peter structs buddy that he bragged
about in his text that was going to be
the FISA judge that signed warrants
where there was no probable cause of
anything this was an attempted coup and
history is bringing that into focus more
and more clearly and what does this
committee do about the abuses the
attempted coup it comes in and decides
we're going to go after the Attorney
General who's trying to clean up the
mess
Christopher rice sure hasn't instead of
asking from the Intel community let us
see the hundred percent certain proof
you have that Hillary Clinton's personal
server was hacked by China
no he covers it up says we still hadn't
seen it well they hadn't asked to see it
there is a disaster that has occurred in
our justice system and this committee
has oversight responsibilities and we
are abusing those this this motion for
contempt is not being done in good faith
I'm not going to call anybody on this
committee the names that my colleague
from Tennessee just did in violation of
our rules of decorum but the truth is we
know that this committee majority is not
acting in good faith how because they're
moving for contempt for an attorney
general failing to turn over material
that this majority at least some maybe
it's just the staff but some people know
that you can't hold someone in contempt
you can vote to do that but you can't be
in contempt for failing to produce
things that are illegal for you to
produce how do we know somebody over
there knows that this is wrong is
because there was an offer look Attorney
General Bart if if you'll join us in
going to court and getting a court order
so that we can get the grand jury
proceedings and evidence then we will
disregard the contempt well that's
evidence of a state of mind by the
majority that at least somebody over
there knows you cannot be contempt for
failing to produce what would be illegal
to produce without a court order
on the wrong side of history and there
is no joy here in seeing the abuses I
hope and pray literally for the day when
we can join forces and quit trying to
push this idea of an attempted coup and
uncover the abuses that have truly gone
on my times expired the committee has to
thank the gentlelady the gentlelady from
Pennsylvania for what purpose does the
gentlelady seek recognition
I move to strike the last word
gentlelady is recognized thank you
you know it's easy to lose focus when
the White House and our colleagues
across the aisle engage in what about
ISM or what is the distraction of the
day or even misleading legal arguments
nobody's asking the Attorney General to
disobey the law we're asking the
Attorney General to obey the law and
produce the Muller report and the
supporting documentation the underlying
evidence that we've been requesting for
a couple months now and that the
American people have been waiting for
two years why is this important well if
you think there's no collusion and no
obstruction you haven't read the Muller
report I admit it's not an easy read but
it clearly states that there was
coordination there's evidence of
coordination it clearly states there are
multiple instances of obstruction of
justice and it clearly refers that over
to Congress to deal with over 700
federal prosecutors have now reviewed
that evidence just the redacted evidence
not even the underlying evidence and
stated unequivocally that it shows
multiple instances that would be
felonies if it was anyone other than a
sitting president and that's the reason
why Muller didn't charge he says in his
report it was a sitting president under
the rules I'm operating under
I couldn't file charges that's why it's
Congress's job to do something about it
and that's why we're staying focused on
our job
I'm not joyful about this I'm not afraid
of where it takes us what I am is
profoundly sad news
that were in a position where we have an
administration that is stonewalling yes
even acting in contempt of not just
Congress not just the rule of law but
the American people and with that I
yield back mr. chairman who seeks
recognition
Sharon what purpose is a general strike
well strike the last word gentleman is
recognized no bars following the law and
what's his reward Democrats are gonna
hold him in contempt I don't think I
don't think today is actually about
getting information I don't think it's
about getting the unredacted mullah
report I don't think last week's hearing
was actually about having staff question
the Attorney General I think it's as my
colleague said earlier I think it's all
about trying to destroy bill bar because
Democrats are nervous he's going to get
to the bottom of everything he's gonna
find out how and why this investigation
started in the first place never forget
what bill Barr said a few weeks ago
three and a half weeks ago when he
testified in front the Senate Finance
Committee said a lot of important things
but he said three excuse me four very
interesting things first he said there
was a failure of leadership at the upper
echelon term he used upper echelon the
FBI we all know that's the case director
Comey has been fire deputy director
McCabe fired lied three times under oath
according to the Inspector General FBI
counsel Jim Baker demoted and left
currently under investigation by the
Justice Department
Lisa paged demoted and left Peter struck
deputy head of counterintelligence
demoted and fired Peter struck the guy
who ran the Clinton investigation and
the Russian investigation there was
certainly a failure of leadership at the
upper echelon of the FBI second thing
the Attorney General said three and a
half weeks ago in front the Senate
Finance Committee spying did occur said
it twice
yes spying did occur third he said
there's a basis for my concern about the
spying that took place and maybe the
most interesting thing two terms he used
frankly I find frightening he said there
was in his judgment he thinks there may
have been unauthorized surveillance and
political surveillance scary terms we
got to go back to January 3rd 2017
Senator Schumer on the Rachel Maddow
Show talking about then president-elect
Trump says this
if you take on the intelligence
community they have six ways from Sunday
at getting back at you I don't know if
the FBI went after President Trump in
six ways but I sure know they went after
him in two ways and the first one is the
now-famous dossier on October 21st 2016
the FBI used one party's opposition
research document as the basis to go to
a secret court to get a warrant to spy
on the other party's campaign that
happened Democratic National Committee
the Clinton campaign paid Perkins cuy
law firm who hired fusing GPS who then
hired a foreigner Christopher Steele who
did what talk to Russians and put
together this salacious unverified
document that became the basis to get a
warrant to spy on the Trump campaign
they did it and when they went to the
court they didn't tell him important
things like who paid for it they didn't
tell him that Christopher Steele had
already told the FBI and the Justice
Department that he was quote desperate
to stop Trump and they didn't tell the
court that Christopher Steele had been
fired by the FBI because he's out
talking to the press they did that and
second just last Thursday just last
Thursday New York Times story FBI sent
investigator posing as an assistant to
meet with the Trump aide in 2016
FBI sent someone in pretending to be
somebody else to talk with George
papadopolis who was with the Trump
campaign you know what they call that
you know what they call that
it's called spying they did it they did
it they did it twice and who knows how
much more and what I know is Bill Barr
has said he's going to get to the bottom
of it and think about the term he used
again this is important political
surveillance in the United States of
America I will not yield
think about that term he's going to get
to the but he said he's going to put a
team together going to investigate all
this this is critical and never forget
the guy who ran this investigation Peter
struck ran the Clinton investigation and
then launched and ran the Trump Russia
investigation never forget what he said
Trump should lose a hundred million to
zero we need an insurance policy
see told Lisa Paige don't worry Lisa
will stop Trump this is what Bill Barre
wants to investigate as other might as
my colleagues have said this is the
House Judiciary Committee with the
history this committee has in protecting
fundamental liberties and protecting the
Constitution last week there was another
important document document image blood
sent to the Attorney General I just want
to read a couple sentences under our
system of government unelected executive
branch officers and intelligence agency
personnel are supposed to answer to the
person elected by the people the
president and not the other way around
this is not a democrat or republican
issue it's a matter of having a
government responsible to the people to
We the People in a partisan in the
partisan commotion surrounding the
Muller report it would be well to
remember that what can be done to a
president can be done to any of us and
this committee is supposed to look out
for that fundamental fact more than
anything else and we are not doing that
today I yield back
I would simply observe that to his
credit
mr. Jordan has been second to none and
asking for access to the materials we're
asking for for the and I simply asked
him does he still think we already did
is he still supporting his own request
for that the committee and the Congress
be given access to the entire report and
the underlying information consistent
with the law and I would ask the
Chairman my understanding is mr. Muller
is gonna be here next week why are we
doing it you're going to get to ask the
guy who wrote the whole darn document
we're all gonna get asking questions why
don't you hold off when this contempt
until at least the guy who wrote the
thing spent 22 months and 35 million
dollars with a whole bunch of Democrat
lawyers putting it together why don't
you wait and ask him next week before we
do this contempt resolution I'll answer
well essentially because it'd be useful
to read the material before we have him
in front of us it's generally the
gentleman what purposes gentleman from
Georgia seek recognition
I move to strike the last word he's
recognized Thank You mr. chairman
for most people in America the end of
the Muller investigation did not take a
check equal the end of the story the
American people want to see and hear the
full story and they deserve to do so and
in fact investigate a Muller intended
for the American people and for Congress
to have the full story he did so in his
unredacted summaries for both the
obstruction and the Russian influence
investigations and what happened when he
issued his report ah William Barr did
something unprecedented he put together
his own full page summary which was
misleading which did which failed to
properly and adequately and accurately
characterized the conclusions of
of the mullah investigators he did that
he waited for about a month while that
narrative marinated among the American
people and it was reduced down to four
words no collusion no obstruction and
they ran with that for a month before
finally the redacted report was issued
by Bob Barr but before he issued the
report two hours before you should the
report he had a press conference to
again summarize the Muller reports
findings and again he failed to
accurately portray and represent those
results and so finally the redacted
report was revealed to Congress and to
the American people in the American
people and Congress saw clearly that Bob
Barr was a part of the president's
ongoing obstruction he obstructs he
obstructed the Russia investigation he
instructed he obstructed all matters
that Muller was investigating and now
he's trying to obstruct Congress and the
American people in finding out what's in
that report and what is very troublesome
is my colleagues on the other side of
the aisle are aiding and abetting them
in their cover-up so still the full
results of the Muller investigation are
not known Congress the House of
Representatives the Judiciary Committee
has demanded an unredacted report that
should be available to all of the
members of at least the House Judiciary
Committee the Attorney General bar has
stonewalled as he has been instructed to
do by the President and he's a willing
participant in this mind you they are
obstructed
the American people's ability to
understand what happened they're hiding
behind ruled 6e of the Federal Rules of
Evidence which make grand jury
proceedings secret but as my colleague
from Wisconsin should know there are
five exceptions listed in 6e that
enabled the disclosure of grand jury
information he knows that there's no
reason for the American people to be
misled about that and Bob William Bar
knows that also and he also knows that
previous Attorney General's in his
situation have gone to Congress have
gone to the courts with the House of
Representatives and obtained grand jury
materials when necessary and so this is
all part of a cover-up and it is up to
this committee to ensure that we get
that report because we have lawful
responsibilities constitutional
responsibilities to to engage in one of
which is possibly impeachment how can we
impeach without getting the documents so
we must get this document the American
people expect us to do it once we get it
our hearings can continue and lead to
whatever they may lead to including
impeachment and so I ask my colleagues
on the other side to stop obscure faith
ops few Kading and start working with us
to carry out your constitutional
responsibilities and with that I yield
back
the for what purpose does the gentleman
from Florida seek recognition
is recognized Thank You mr. chairman
glad glad to see that the microphones
working this week my good friend from
Georgia just asked the operative
question how can we impeach if we don't
get the documents how can we impeach if
we don't get the documents ladies and
gentlemen this hearing is not about the
Attorney General it's not about the
Muller report 92% of which everyone in
America's had the opportunity to read
it's not about the fact that even the
portions that the American people
haven't been able to read the Chairman's
been able to go read had he chosen this
is all about impeaching the president
now why don't they just say it why don't
they just jump to the impeachment
proceedings like their liberal media
overlords are telling them to do well
the reason is that the American people
don't support impeachment and it's easy
to understand why they actually went and
elected Donald Trump president United
States and I don't think people are
gonna support impeaching a president
who's doing so well I mean you got three
point two percent growth in the economy
the Trump economy is hot and the reason
we're doing so well is consequence of
the president's policies and so at a
time when my Democrat colleagues are
focused on the next election and not
solutions to the problems facing
Americans they can't attack the
president's policies as people are doing
well so typically they roll next to
identity politics that based on what you
look like who you pray to or who you
love
you can't possibly support Republicans
but African Americans are doing better
Hispanics are doing better women are
doing better we are seeing a rising tide
that is truly lifting all boats in this
country and so now we have this effort
not to argue with policies not to
typically go to the identity politics
that functions is the organizing
principle of today's Democratic Party
they have to deal ajith amaizing
the legitimize the guy that people voted
for but they don't have the guts to do
it directly and so they're going after
the Attorney General now the gentleman
from Georgia in his last remarks said we
are hiding behind the rules hiding
behind the rules these are federal laws
that dictate what the Attorney General
can and cannot do we're not hiding
behind the rules we just like to follow
them
by the way it's not following the rules
that got us in this trouble in the first
place when the Inspector General
testified before us he said it's the
fundamental fact that during the
investigations of Hillary Clinton and
Donald Trump
you saw continuous examples of a one-off
here a violation of protocol there the
Inspector General said never before had
he seen a circumstance where the very
same team that was investigating Hillary
Clinton would then go and investigate
the other person that was involved in
the 2016 presidential contest about a
month ago in this committee I laid out
the stages of grief denial anger
bargaining depression and acceptance and
I think that folks watching at home can
probably follow along and see where
we're headed first my Democratic
colleagues were in denial when they saw
that there was no collusion after saying
for 22 months that the president was an
agent of the Russian government after
saying for 22 months that there was
actual evidence of collusion
they were in denial when they saw the
conclusion that there wasn't then there
was anger it had to be the Attorney
General's fault Mahler didn't make a
decision on obstruction somebody had to
the Attorney General did so they got bad
at him and went this whole kerfuffle of
anger well now we know the third step
bargaining
well mr. Attorney General you've given
us 92% of the Muller report but we have
to bargain for the remaining 8% because
that's really where we think the action
is well mr. attorney general you spent
five hours before the Senate Judiciary
Committee three of our presidential
candidates got to question you you
offered to come before the House
Judiciary Committee you offered to come
for an additional hour of questioning
but we have to bargain so that our staff
lawyers can ask you questions now I
don't think it's a good sign that the
next sign after bargaining is depression
so I I feel for my Democrat colleagues
but after that we get to acceptance and
that's sure something that I'm looking
forward to because there are some really
good ideas that my Democratic colleagues
have once they kind of get to acceptance
on the no Russia collusion thing my
friend the gentleman from Rhode Island
has excellent ideas about how to change
the way that consumers interface with
big tech companies my colleague from the
state of New York is right that if the
first stepped act is the only step act
then there's then that would be a bad
thing we need to do more on criminal
justice reform my colleague who's not
with us from California mr. swallow well
he's got great ideas to unlock potential
cures with medical cannabis reform but
we're not doing any of those things and
by the way I've got a bunch of my
friends on the other side of the aisle
low-key wish that their actual bills
that would impact the lives of Americans
would get heard instead of this garbage
the Obama administration ran an Intel
operation against the Trump campaign
Peter struck opened it up the dossier
kept it going and now the Democrats need
to get over it I yield back mr. chairman
mr. Chairman I move to strike the last
word the gentleman from Florida seek
recognition mr. Clark mr. chan is
recognized Thank You mr. chairman
we're here today because we're
witnessing the breakdown of the
foundations of our nation's
constitutional order that's why we're
here today in 1974 in US v Nixon the
Supreme Court warned of moments just
like this when they said once executive
privilege is asserted co-equal branches
of the government are set on a collision
course the court went on to explain that
such a collision and I quote places
courts in the awkward position of
evaluating the executives claims of
confidentiality and autonomy and pushes
to the fore difficult questions of
separations of separation of power and
checks and balances these occasions for
constitutional confrontation between the
two branches are likely to be avoided
whenever possible why are we on this
collision course today because the
Attorney General of the United States
refused to provide information that is
not privileged and is subject to the
committee's subpoena the committee
issued a subpoena for information
gathered by the special counsel there's
no privilege for this information
executive privilege is not a cloak of
secrecy that drapes across our nation's
capitol from the White House to the
Justice Department yet last night the
Attorney General threatened a blanket
privilege claim over materials that he
knows are not privileged as retribution
for the markup that we're holding right
now and this morning he asked the
President to do just that it's striking
how empty that gesture is chairman
Naylor pointed this out last night the
Attorney General's request of a blank or
privileged claim is empty of any
credibility it's empty of merit it's
empty of any legal or factual support
the Attorney General ordered his staff
to send what he would define as a snitty
letter last night but those words were
empty executive privilege exists to help
the presidency function to ensure that
the president gets good advice and can
make important decisions without
interference from Congress but that's
not at stake here we're asking for
information that is no longer held in
confidence among the president and his
closest advisors we're just asking for
the truth
the truth that many already know but is
being withheld from the public
investigators know the truth private
attorneys know the truth the ranking
member of this committee has seen it the
privilege no longer applies
what does apply as the American people's
interest in the truth and the need for
this committee to do its job to protect
our elections to protect our national
security to hold the president
accountable and to draft legislation to
ensure that no one not the Attorney
General not the president is above the
law yet the Attorney General continues
to mislead the American people and after
being caught in a lie and his testimony
to Congress he has now joined the
president in ongoing obstruction of the
house congressional hearings and
document requests are normal their
normal this committee holds an oversight
hearing with the Attorney General every
year that is normal but this this
collision course the President and
attorney general set us on is not normal
this collision is the definition of a
constitutional crisis and the breadth of
this obstruction is beyond anything in
our nation's history the president has
said that Muller should not testify here
he has ordered without authority Don
maganda refused to testify here he has
ordered in violation of the law that the
Treasury secretary continued to hide his
tax returns
he has blocked or delayed more than 30
requests from Congress
he has blocked testimony about the
security clearances granted to his
family members
he has blocked testimony about the
humanitarian disaster caused by by the
Trump family separation policy at our
southern border this sweeping
repudiation of Congress and
congressional investigations is
unprecedented and it is unconstitutional
this is a government of By and For the
People the Attorney General of the
United States is stonewalling the people
he is misleading the people and he is
working actively working to suppress
truth I don't understand still every
time we have one of these hearings how
it is that none of my colleagues on the
other side of the aisle seem at all
concerned about Russia's attack on our
democracy and their desire to do it
again and I close with this the mauler
report finishes by reminding us that the
protection of the criminal justice
system from corrupt acts by any person
including the president accords with the
fundamental principle of our government
that no person in this country is so
high that he is above the law we will
continue to assert our oversight
Authority out of a duty to maintain the
checks and balances that preserve the
powers of separation and co-equal
branches of government a failure to do
so would be a failure of our
constitutional system of government I
know back my purpose is the gentleman
from Colorado seek recognition to have
an amendment at the desk
the clerk will report the amendment
I mean mr. Chairman I reserve a point of
order gentleman reserves a point of
order
you
you
you
you
as chairman mr. chairman what purposes
gentleman from Louisiana seek
recognition move to strike last word the
gentleman from I whither all my member
because it's not ready at this point and
I appreciate that the gentleman from
Louisiana is recognized for five minutes
Thank You mr. chairman we have heard
some extraordinary claims this morning
I've been taking notes as my colleagues
have have commented on all of this a
congresswoman Sheila Jackson Lee said
the executive branch is quote taking a
wrecking ball to the Constitution and
mr. chairman you said that the DOJ
doesn't recognize Congress as a co-equal
branch of government or acknowledge our
oversight responsibilities mr. Cohen
said we're trampling upon article 1
anyone who looks at these facts
objectively knows the truth is exactly
the opposite the Attorney General and
the DOJ are objecting to this charade
based upon the rule of law they are
trying to protect the integrity of our
institutions and mr. chairman you said
that the preliminary protective
assertion of executive privilege this
morning was a last-minute outburst it's
exactly the opposite of that
in fact the letter that the the DOJ sent
to you this morning says and I quote
regrettably you mr. chairman have made
this assertion necessary by your
assistants insistence upon scheduling a
premature contempt vote the letter goes
on to say you've terminated our ongoing
negotiations and abandoned abandoned the
accommodation process and as we have
repeatedly explained the Attorney
General could not comply with your
subpoena in its current form without
violating the law court rules in court
orders and without threatening the
independence of the Department of
Justice's prosecutorial functions that's
a quoting from the letter the facts
matter the letter that the Attorney
General sent to the president this
morning that accompanies all this says
quote the committee demands all of the
special counsels investigative files
which consists of everybody list and
consists of millions of pages of
classified and unclassified documents
bearing upon more than two dozen
criminal cases and investigations many
of which are ongoing these materials
include law enforcement information
information about sensitive intelligence
sources
methods and grand jury information that
the department is prohibited from
disclosing by law that's the letter the
Attorney General sent to the president
explaining all this look we're attorneys
on here most of us are attorneys on this
committee what does the law say the
courts have repeatedly affirmed the
rules on all this April fifth just last
month the US Court of Appeals for the DC
Circuit ruled in Makeba versus Barr the
district courts may disclose grand jury
materials only where they have positive
authority to do so particularly through
the exceptions to grand jury secrecy
listed in rule 6 e the court of
explained the vital interests they said
that the rule of grand jury secrecy
seeks to protect including preserving
the willingness and candor of witnesses
called before the grand jury not
alerting the target of investigation who
might otherwise flee or interfere with a
grand jury and preserving the rights of
a suspect who might later be exonerated
these are critically important
principles and traditions for up to us
to uphold and it is again the law that
the Chairman can file suit for access to
the 6e material but instead he blasts
the Attorney General for not joining him
and doing so why hasn't the Chairman
taken that step I think I know why
perhaps because he knows that his
rationale for demanding the unredacted
report is wholly insufficient this bares
repeating the Chairman claims he needs
the full unredacted report as part of
the March 4th 2019 investigation into
the 81 individuals and organizations
related in some way to President Trump
but let's make a couple of facts clear
the investigation we don't even know if
it's still ongoing we haven't heard much
about it lately
the lack of activities surrounding the
investigations makes clear the the
majority here is not interested in
pursuing this for any legitimate
legislative purpose this is about
scoring political points
the Chairman's public comments
surrounding his need for the full report
are almost exclusively focused on
obstruction but another important fact
here 99.9% of the obstruction volume is
available right now for the Chairman to
view but he hasn't done that only six
lines and over 182 pages is redacted in
the obstruction volume this is not about
seeking the truth as we've heard this
morning it's about raw partisan politics
our Democrat colleagues have weaponized
critical oversight responsibilities and
moving today to hold the AG in contempt
is not only premature unprecedented and
unwarranted frankly it is shameful I
think we believe the American people
deserve better I hope that they'll
review the facts I hope they'll look at
all this correspondence I hope they'll
get beyond all this cloud of partisan
politics and understand why we are
taking the stand today that we are I
yield back
for what purpose does gentleman from
Louisiana seek unity mr. Chairman I
would move to strike the last word
gentleman is recognized
mr. Chairman I would just say that today
is a very serious day today is a very
regrettable day unfortunately we have an
administration that is choosing to have
a temper tantrum that is designed to
accomplish one thing and that one thing
is to never let the real facts of the
Muller report come to light to never let
the American people hear the whole story
the other side would have us
congratulate them for telling 92% of the
story I wish when I was a child I could
get away with telling 92 percent of the
story to my mother I would always tell
the same good 92 percent and I would
leave all the bad deeds lies and crimes
in the 8 percent that I don't tell so
you get no profile and courage you don't
get the Nobel Peace Prize and you
certainly don't get any award for
honesty for giving out 92% of the whole
story to the American people
but the real story of what we're doing
today is that the president needed
something to hang his head on to prevent
anyone who had anything to do with
compiling the report from putting their
hand on a Bible and taking a boat to
tell the truth and that's what we're
going to ultimately have is the
president obstructing a testimony of
everyone involved in the Muller report
while he tells the National people and
continues to promote and articulate and
push and offer lies and fake news about
the contents of the report without ever
letting the American people see the
whole truth and nothing but the true but
I will tell the American people that are
watching today that we have a solemn
obligation to the Constitution we have a
solemn obligation to defend our
democracy to protect the homeland to
protect the right of the American
citizens to have a free open fair
election without the interference of any
foreign countries especially Russia
the bad news is that this is this will
never be neat this will never be clean
this will never be easy this will never
be convenient this will be messy but the
one thing that the American people
should know is that we're here at the
right time to protect our democracy and
that the Democrats are not going to give
up on our constitutional duty we're not
going to run or abandon this country or
our citizens we will never run we will
never retreat when we're fighting to
save our country and for the messiness
it will be that way sometimes but the
fight is necessary to protect this great
country and to continue to move it
towards being a more perfect union there
are too many people in this country's
history that have given their life blood
sweat and tears to get us to be the
great country that we are today we will
not let one administration certainly not
one person we will not let one party be
enablers to the criminal acts that we
see over and over again so just so that
I can deal and speak in facts so people
won't just think that they're the
Democrats go again there have been a
hundred and ninety-nine criminal acts
that have come out of the investigation
there have been 37 34 individuals
charged with crimes there have been
three companies charged with crimes so
let's just look at the orbit around this
administration and see how faith this is
the former campaign manager in jail
former national security adviser in jail
the president's personal lawyer in jail
this is not a witch-hunt if it looks
like a duck walks like a duck and quacks
like a duck it's a duck and if it looks
like obstruction
sounds like obstruction smells like
obstruction it's obstruction Thank You
mr. chairman I yield back mr. chairman
gentlemen what purpose does the
gentleman from Arizona seek recognition
move to strike the last word and it was
recognized Thank You mr. chairman
you know last week we saw an attempt to
change the rules of this committee that
defied the historical precedent of by
applying only impeachment proceedings to
Attorney General William bar and today
we're sipping right along and we know
that my colleagues on the other side
have the votes
they're gonna try to hold this Attorney
General in contempt but I'm I'm
interested to see the look on the judges
face when my colleagues from the other
side present the these are these facts
of course gonna say what you do we're in
negotiations well we were but we kind of
see scuttled that because we refused to
hear from the Attorney General because
we changed the rules you know mr. judge
we changed the rules so the Attorney
General didn't come in I he offered to
let us view the less redacted report but
I didn't do that I didn't I didn't even
bother to go down there and look at that
report
he offered to have staff members view
the less redacted report with me I know
I said no we're not going to do that
either he permitted us to take notes on
the less redacted report and we rejected
that as well
he asked us to continue to negotiate see
if we could work out our differences but
I rejected that as well
we attempted to compel him to respond in
spite of federal law on rule 60 the
grand jury material we've heard so much
about today
we knew that there were some other
witnesses that were important that might
have shed light on this as well but we
didn't hold the hearing with da Jie
Rosenstein
we didn't hold the hearing on Muller
before we issued our contempt citation
we didn't seek closed-door confidential
classified hearings with any of these
individuals in fact judge you know we
did
we undercut our whole argument by making
the argument to mr. Barr saying hey look
you know mr. Barr why don't you just
join us why don't you just join us in
asking the court to authorize release of
60 material what does that do it says
quite frankly that the folks that will
be sitting there before a court
propounding execution of a contempt
citation they're gonna have the great
privilege of saying yeah we put a sword
of Damocles over William bar we created
a Hobson's choice we said guess what mr.
Barr you either get held in contempt or
you violate federal law because that's
just the way we do things and Judiciary
Committee these days that's just the way
it is that is unprecedented and it will
hold this committee up to derision and
as my colleague mr. Johnson from
Louisiana said there was a case that
just came out last month which said and
this is this gets to my colleague from
Georgia who said you can't be misled
there are exceptions that's right and
the and the court said you must fit
within one of those exceptions before
you can release rule 6 e material but
don't be misled because nothing we're
doing here today fits in to the rule 6 e
exceptions there's not an authorization
under the 60 provisions right now so
there's going to be a problem and I
can't wait to see the judge to look on
the judges face when these guys try to
explain well we were trying to
pigeonhole into something of 60 and then
I'll just close in this area when I hear
that the wrecking ball is being taken to
the Constitution that it's being
trampled upon that wears
continued breakdown the constitutional
order these kind of arguments made over
and over again I can't help but say if
you think this administration this
president is so dangerous
where's why aren't you acting on the
mini resolutions for impeachment you've
already introduced I mean
mr. Johnson was pretty clear this whole
thing is about impeachment well take you
to the American people take it
file your resolution you've already
filed them act on them with that my time
is up thank you
a general for what purposes gentleman
from New York seek recognition
I move to strike the last word enemies
recognize I don't first to say that I
expect that when the court does hear
this challenge if it comes today I
expect that she will rule in favor of
the constitutional separation and checks
and balances in our oversight function I
really don't understand the arguments
that have been articulated by my
colleagues and as I understand it there
have been three different reasons that
have been suggested for opposing our
effort to simply uphold our article 1
responsibility as a separate and
co-equal branch of government one that
this whole thing is a politically
inspired witch-hunt nonsense
two they won all of a sudden protect the
reputation or interests of innocent
Americans nonsense
3 this blanket assertion of executive
privilege nonsense let's take all three
first of all 17 different intelligence
agencies have concluded that Russia
interfered with our election attacked
our democracy for the sole purpose of
artificially placing someone at 1600
Pennsylvania Avenue they were successful
and that's also what the Mulla report
shows this is not a politically inspired
witch-hunt I'm confused
every single person at the helm of this
investigation is a Republican the person
who initiated the investigation former
FBI director James Comey Republican the
FBI director who replaced him and
presided over the investigation
Christopher Rea Republican the person
who decided to appoint a special counsel
to preside over the investigation and
then monitored it at the helm of the
Department of Justice the Deputy
Attorney General Rod Rosenstein
Republican a person who actually
conducted the investigation a war hero a
law enforcement professional Bob Muller
time republican who's the Attorney
General going to investigate the
Republican Party the notion that it's a
politically inspired witch-hunt is just
one of 10,000 or more misrepresentations
that have been spun out of 1600
Pennsylvania Avenue it's a shame that
you choose to adopt it and parrot it
second thing with reputation or
interests really many of my colleagues
on the other side of the aisle actually
perpetrated a witch hunt as it relates
to securing more than eight hundred
thousand documents from this very same
Department of Justice without regard to
the reputation of interest of Americans
who have served this country you weren't
concerned with the reputational
interests of Hillary Clinton in fact the
top Republicans said that the sole
objective was to undermine her the
former First Lady and Secretary of State
you weren't concerned with the
reputation or interest of Peter struck
and Lisa Paige in fact you embarrassed
those two they made mistakes but you
embarrassed those two you are concerned
with the reputational interest of Andy
McCabe so don't peddle that phony
argument to us this very same Department
of Justice turned over 800,000 pages of
documents but they won't turn over a
single page pursuant to a legitimately
issued subpoena and then you want to
assert executive privilege are you
kidding me you can't assert executive
privilege after the fact when the
closest advisors to the president have
already spoken to team Muller wait a
second let's try to go through this
White House Counsel Don McCain talked to
Muller
there is no assertion of executive
privilege White House press secretary
Sarah Huckabee Sanders talked to Muller
no assertion of executive privilege
House communications director hope Hicks
talked to Muller it was no assertion of
executive privilege it's a phony
argument the house is a separate and
co-equal branch of government we're not
a wholly owned subsidiary of the Trump
administration we don't work for Donald
Trump we work for the American people we
have a constitutional responsibility to
serve as a check and balance on an
out-of-control executive branch the
Attorney General is totally out of
control he will be held in contempt of
Congress I yield back
what purposes a gentleman from
California seek recognition gentleman is
recognized
Thank You mr. chairman this subpoena
puts the Attorney General in legal
catch-22 to comply with the subpoena he
must break the law if he obeys the law
he must disobey the subpoena every
person on this committee knows that the
law forbids release of grand jury
testimony Congress is the law making
branch of government of this committee
feels it's so important to see the grand
jury testimony it can change the law but
it cannot order the highest ranking law
enforcement official in our country to
break that law the American people can
plainly see what's going on here for
two-and-a-half years they have been
force-fed a brazen and monstrous lie
that the President of the United States
is a traitor who's loyal to a foreign
and hostile power Robert Mueller was
given extraordinary powers to
investigate this he appointed one of the
most partisan and biased teams of
investigators that has ever been pointed
to was substantiate these charges they
spent 22 months and 25 million dollars
in direct and component costs doing so
they employed some of the most abusive
tactics among them perjury traps and
threatening family members in order to
turn up some shred of evidence to
confirm this narrative the Trump
administration gave them every document
they requested and even waived
attorney-client privilege to make the
president's personal attorney available
for 30 hours of testimony though the
President had the clear constitutional
authority to terminate or interfere with
the investigation he did not well after
all that they were forced to admit that
there's not a shred of evidence to
support this lie we're now learning it
was predicated on a fake dossier
fabricated by the Clinton campaign and
was used by the highest ranking
officials of the Department of Justice
the FBI our intelligence agencies and
perhaps even the White House first to
try to influence the outcome of our
election and after failing that to
undermine the duly elected president of
the United States and tear this country
apart now that lies laid bare for all to
see
the left's head now to think up a new
lion think it up quick us in a heartbeat
the lie changed from collusion to
obstruction that even though the
administration did nothing to interfere
or impede the investigation
the president's guilty of obstruction
just because he complained about the
injustice of it all behind closed doors
in words that are mounted to no action
whatsoever they know this lie won't hold
up under scrutiny either so what to do
well well the answer to that questions
before us right now
even though there was no legal
requirement for the Mueller report to be
released publicly the Attorney General
has released it with the sole exception
of material he is legally forbidden to
release ninety to ninety two percent of
the document he's offered the chairman
and the ranking member of this committee
the opportunity to review the additional
redactions that can be reviewed in a
classified setting leaving only about
six lines out of a hundred and eighty
two pages but instead of reviewing that
information or changing the law to allow
for its public release they order the
Attorney General to do what he legally
cannot do and then charge there's a
cover-up they imply the smoking gun is
now in that six lines and over a hundred
and eighty two pages that cannot be
legally shared safe in the knowledge
they'll never be called out on it and
they hope that there will be enough of a
smokescreen to cover the perversion of
our justice and intelligence agencies
for political purposes under the Obama
administration one other point last week
the Democrats voted to change rules of
the committee to allow members to hide
behind committee counsel to challenge
the Attorney General mr. chairman we
don't hire people to speak for us on the
House floor and we shouldn't hire people
to speak for us in committee only
members of the House should speak in
house proceedings and there's a reason
for that we're responsible and
accountable for what we say in public
forums in this public forum hired help
is not the only rightful exception is
when we sit as a tribunal and
impeachment because then we're sitting
as a jury
here evidence any exceptions from this
makes a mockery of representative
democracy based on the direct
accountability that representatives of
the people must have to those who
elected them I yield back